Let's go next to our caller from the.
Six six two area code.
Who's calling today from six six two.
Hey, David.
Yes.
I have a quick question.
Boring.
Okay.
Give me what I want.
Just hold on one second.
Let's see if we can clean up the connection
a little bit.
Are we on speaker phone right now?
We are OK, sorry.
Here, Airpark.
I thought that was OK.
OK.
Very good.
I was good.
It seems like whatever noise was happening
in the background has been resolved.
Who's this?
Where are you calling from?
This is Roar's conference, Denver, Colorado.
Great.
What's going on today?
I think it's a lot of tempo and he's taking
that.
A lot of people are lying to the pollsters
about Biden and thinking they're just like
really going to vote for Trump.
There's like a silent majority, especially
with, like, his economic pribyl rating is
like at 58 percent.
Just wanted to know what your thoughts were
on that.
I haven't.
I mean, I've not seen this assertion made.
I don't I don't know what Tim is saying.
I think you have to defend such an assertion
with evidence and merely pointing to higher
economic approval than support for Trump.
Wouldn't really be evidence.
It could just as easily be evidence that despite
feeling that things are okay economically,
people still are going to vote for Biden over
Trump.
Like, we're it's it's one of these.
It's an indefeasible argument.
You can't possibly make a counterpoint because
implicitly it's that people are not telling
the truth.
So if by death, if your argument is people
are lying, we wouldn't be able to disprove
that until people actually vote in November.
So we kind of have to just wait and see.
OK.
But I think that also happened 2016.
I think people are ashamed to say, hey, I'm
not not a Trump supporter, but I'm going to.
In what sense did it happen?
And to hold on, whatever we did, we had that
happily 2016.
What's that?
What evidence do we have that it happened
in 2016?
Because everyone thought that it was going
to be a blowout victory for Hillary.
I mean, like The New York Times.
What was it like an hour Huffington Post over
the 93 percent chance.
I was going to win.
Okay.
No.
But let's hope.
So these are we're now.
So I think this is a good opportunity to to
think about some of these things that in a
couple different ways.
So The New York Times, I think, said on Election
Day that it was like a 70 percent chance that
Hillary won now.
What you know, that when they say that they're
not predicting Hillary gets 70 percent of
the votes, a 70 percent chance to win means
that if you run 100 elections with the inputs
we had in 70 of them, Hillary would win and
in 30, Trump would win.
So that part you understand, right?
Yes.
OK, good.
And so then the second part is the polling
on Election Day was that Hillary was ahead
nationally by three point two.
And she won by two point one, which is within
the margin, the stated margin of error.
So the national polls were were correct in
2016.
But I just really think the Democrats are
playing with fire when they're talking about
defunding the police, when there's like a
poll that came out that like 88 percent of
people are satisfied with, the police are
either want more funding and only Whitesell
percent want to defund the police.
Right.
So now.
But so now you're now making a totally different
argument.
Your first argument was that in 2016, people
lied about supporting Hillary.
Now you're saying defund the police is a bad
idea.
You're you're acknowledging we're now on to
something different, right?
Yes.
OK.
Go back now.
I agree with you.
I think that the I don't know if you saw my
clip, but the poll I saw says only 16 percent
of the country supports defund.
I think it's the wrong messaging.
I've put out a much more specific plan that
is about demilitarize and retrain and re delegate
and stuff like that.
So on this issue, I agree with you.
But on the issue that in 2016, people lied
about supporting Hillary.
The data don't back that up.
All right, maybe I'll have to look more into
it, but David, I appreciate it, Campbell.
Good morning.
Right.
But I do use your show to get a more balanced
perspective.
And I appreciate what you do, man.
All right.
Thank you for the call very much.
Appreciate it.
I think hopefully we were able to resolve
a few factual misunderstandings there.
I venture to say,